nfl film senior producer greg cosell
back here on the program how are you
greg
rich i'd rather talk about the streets
of san francisco do you remember that
show
michael douglas and carl muller maldon
one of the all-time greats oh
yes well i'll i'll put a pin in that for
16 minutes from now
one of my favorite shows growing up well
you know what um
michael doug has been at it for a while
i zoomed with him uh yesterday and we're
gonna play that
um uh with him we played that
conversation with him shortly i did ask
him what his
his oldest residual check is um and
actually it predates
streets of san francisco so that's how
wow yes
that's an answer that's coming on the
show all right well speaking of dusting
off tape
let's talk about jordan loves tape um
and
uh because i think this is where this is
headed at least for green bay as they're
playing out their end of this gambit
right now it's like okay
you know we drafted him he might not be
ready but we're gonna go for it
uh what was your evaluation of jordan
love going into the 2020 draft because
we didn't see him suit up at all
last year correct well you know i
watched jordan loves 2018 tape in his
2019 tape
and i remember in the summer when i
watched his 2018 tape
i really thought that he was a high
level prospect i thought he had arm
strength i thought he had pace and touch
i thought he threw the ball with good
accuracy i thought he was athletic he
could move
i thought he was an easy natural thrower
so coming off the 2018 tape before his
2019 season i said to myself if this guy
has a really good
2019 season this guy could be a top five
pick
and then we got to 2019 and 2019 was not
as good
the traits are still there because
traits tend to be traits rich
you know it's not as if all of a sudden
he had a bad arm
um but there were a number of issues
that
prevented him from being as consistent
as he was in 2018
and i thought that he had mechanical
issues with his footwork
um i thought that he did not throw
consistently with a firm base and he was
not on balance
and when you don't throw with a firm
base and you're not on balance
your accuracy really gets impacted in a
negative way
i thought he had a tendency to drift to
his left when he threw the ball
so he would kind of lean to his left
rather than standing straight up and
delivering
i thought he dropped his arm angle when
he didn't need to so
all of a sudden he developed these
mechanical issues
that really impacted uh his consistency
his ability to
to play to his what are essentially
scheme transcendent traits
so obviously i'm not there in green bay
i don't know what happened last year
when he was a rookie i don't know what
they're working on with him
but he has strong quarterback traits the
question is can they come out
so when he was coming out in 2020
where did you place him amongst the 2020
draftees that eventually went we all
know burrow and
two and herbert at the top where did you
where did you play i didn't i didn't put
him at that level
even though his traits would have
suggested that he could be at that level
um you know i don't remember
specifically how i
i had them mapped out right um but he
was not
he was not that guy um
but you know he's one of those guys to
me that's that's
difficult and then this is where it gets
hard when you're
in the evaluation of quarterbacks
because you can look at at
love and you say wow this guy's got a
lot to work with
um and this is where you have to know
the player talk to the player
see him throw live go through the entire
process which i don't do obviously i
don't work for a team
and that helps you so i don't know what
the result of that was for teams
obviously the packers saw something
because they traded up to get him in the
first round
when they had aaron rodgers in his prime
on their roster
but i think we know how matt laflore
really would
like to play because they drafted aj
dillon in the second round
and they have aj dylan they have aaron
jones
so i think he wants to start his offense
with the run game
and have the quarterback work off that
and there's many many ways to do that
effectively
and still have your quarterback be a big
factor but
you know i think they're telling you
that matt leflore is kind of telling you
how he envisions his offense so greg
cosell here
uh on the rich eisen show where would
you have placed jordan love
in the 2021 draft class that we're all
more freshly familiar with you us the
listeners
viewers of this program where where
would you have placed jordan love
amongst the
five that went in the first round in the
top half of the first round
as well greg you know i think you'd
still have to put trevor lawrence at the
top
um you know i think wilson probably
would would go before love
um but i think in some ways you could
say that from a skill set perspective
skill set
yes again that you could say that that
love
and justin fields probably have some
similarities
um now i think the way you know don't
forget
fields had some very inconsistent
moments as well
in in the 2020 season he also had some
special
moments which love did not have those
special moments
in his 2020 uh 19 tape where his fields
had
some special moments in 2020. what about
certainly what about the landing back
from the injury
you know and really showing something
that toughness mental and physical
toughness
i think that raised his profile uh in
the minds of a lot of people
what about lance what about trey lance
greg where do you place jordan
yeah i like freelance traits a lot and
he's certainly um
i would say that love is is a better
thrower than lance
when they in terms of when they came out
that's what i'm talking about
and that's and i understand that that's
the conundrum of this conversation greg
is that but but again love is
technically coming out you know what i
mean like there was no tape on him last
year he did not play
i didn't dress he was number three all
year long i mean he's gotten reps
uh on scout team aaron jones was on the
show a couple
weeks ago when i was kicking the tires
on on on
any possibility of revealing the
relationship in green bay and he said
that
rogers was terrific with love and
mentoring him and answering questions
and pointing things out to him when they
were on a practice field but other than
that
i mean we are really in the in the first
blush evaluation
with him in the same way that you know
we haven't seen lance play a snap
since obviously uh week one of the
then covert cancelled season we haven't
seen love
to play a snap since 2019 and now you're
right
and i think that love is in is an easy
thrower a natural thrower
more so than lance lance gives you much
more
in the quarterback run game lance has
more second reaction movement
improvisational ability
um so uh you know i
like i said i thought love was a really
intriguing prospect there's no question
that there were meaningful
inconsistencies in his game
but you know i've talked to a lot of
coaches over the years as you well know
richard
very few guys come out where you feel
like this guy's really ready to play
so then it comes to how is he coached
what system is he in how can you help
him by defining things for him
clearly as he's learning the position at
the nfl level
so there's so many factors that go into
play and i can guarantee that green bay
that coaching staff that entire staff
and organization
they have a sense of jordan love because
they're with him every day we're not
um you know all i have is the last time
i saw him play which was 2019 in college
greg cosell here on the rich eisen show
and again i know you don't work for team
as you pointed out you work for nfl
films but you
you've you've been around uh the block
to say the least
uh if a team was interested in acquiring
jordan love
what type of prospect would you say
would he be ready to play in a year he's
ready to play maybe now
i mean again i know you don't know
what's going on behind the scenes
but like if there is somebody that has a
year or two to play with
potentially one year to play with with
their veteran quarterbacks say
pittsburgh
washington another team that gets
mentioned a lot these days because you
know we're twiddling our thumbs waiting
to get some sort of resolution and all
this in the media is atlanta
um you know certainly with julio jones
needing to maybe
move elsewhere based on his desires as
well as the cap space and
problem that atlanta has what would you
say to a team that might be just
let's take a flyer on calling gudekuns
for this guy in case he wants to get out
from his rogers
problem well assuming normal development
with jordan love i would think that
he'd be ready to play and when i say
ready to play i don't mean he he'll be a
top 10 quarterback rich i mean
but he's he's been in the league for
a year he's he's seen one of the best
ever perform
both in practice and in games
and i'm told by someone who was on the
coaching staff there in green bay for
years that rogers
is the smartest quarterback he that he's
ever seen just in his ability to see
things
at the speed with which you need to see
things um
you know love was a
basically a three-year starter in
college at least two and a half years so
it's not as if you're dealing with a kid
that did not have meaningful college
experience
so many of these kids now are coming out
with 15 starts 16 start 17 starts
love had you know 30 plus starts if i'm
not mistaken
um so he has meaningful college
experience he's been
in the league for a year you would have
to assume and teams would know this
because everybody knows what's going on
with every other team but you'd have to
assume that this kid is ready to line up
and take a snap
in in meaningful games now then you have
to decide what you want your offense to
look like if he's your quarterback
and how you need to help him work
through the process
but you'd have to believe he's ready to
play so are the packers constituted to
support him should he have to go in 2021
what do you think i would think that the
answer to that in a very general sense
would be yes
because as i said they drafted aj dillon
in the second round for a reason
they resigned aaron jones you could
almost look at their backfield
in some ways like the saints where aj
dillon is kind of the latavius murray
and then jones is kind of the chimera
because last year jones
kind of morphed and evolved into a guy
that they were not going to
feature as a foundation back with 250
280 carries
he was going to be more of a 170 to 200
carry guy
and they were going to have a second
back and now you have aj dylan
um the key for that kind of thing is is
also your defense because the last thing
you want with
love is to be in situations where you
feel as if you have to drop him back by
choice 35 40 times a game yeah
brother half rogers if that's the case
huh well no question and i thought
rogers quite honestly
i thought he was phenomenal last year oh
yeah you know
i thought he was so so good playing
within the structure of that offense he
just to me
you know we you kind of lose sight of
how really good he was
even with the mvp i agree with you so
before i let you go
greg um now that we're through the draft
which prospect you think is in the
position
scheme-wise to be uh highly successful
herbert-like
weak are you talking about the
quarterback yes sir which quarterback
wound up in the spot where you're like
okay i think uh i think we've got a
possibility to get um
a highly successful surprise season
out of this person even if it doesn't
amount to to wins
but just i'll tell you the guy and i'm
you know it's it's the end of may right
so we don't know the answer to any of
this or just started you know with otas
and
uh and all that stuff now so we have no
idea you know teams say a lot of things
now
just because they have to they have to
yes i
i really think trey lance is in a really
good position and i don't know if he'll
be the starter we really don't know
obviously they still have jimmy
garoppolo
and the assumption is that jimmy
garoppolo is the starter
but i i think if trey lance has a really
really good offseason in training camp
it would not surprise me to see trey
lance end up being the starter sooner
than later
and i think he's in a really good
position with that team
they've got a plethora of running backs
really good backs
they've got an improved offensive line
they've got weapons on the outside
they've got
kittle i mean i think this team
offensively is a fascinating team and
they've got kyle shanahan
who is such a good designer of offense
with a great
understanding of how to deploy his
personnel
i actually think trey lance is in a
really fascinating situation
you imagine they get julio jones too
greg you imagine if that happens
yeah now of course julio i guess played
for kyle for a year maybe two but i know
it's for at least
a year obviously so um oh yeah i mean
that
who knows how that's going to play out
the falcons are in salary cap hell
yes they are and there's there's one way
out of it and the one
certainly that involves a player who uh
potentially unwittingly it seems
saying i'm out of here does not want to
be there for what we've heard i guess
it's what we did here greg thanks for
the call really appreciate it we'll
we'll check back in during the summer
again thanks again thanks
really appreciate it you better i follow
greg cosell on twitter greg cosell you
should too
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here